was wir jetzt machen wir spielen einfach
mal als wende tisch
hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen mal wieder zu einem statement
spiel vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch an
die alten stimmen videos erinnern wenn
nicht verlinkt ich euch mal alle hier in
der liste da müsstet ihr gleich drauf
klicken können und dann gilt sind die
anderen die schaut ihr euch am besten
danach an die haben eigentlich alle so
einen gewissen ablauf wonach man die
nacheinander spielen soll
luca hat die einfach komplett
durcheinander gespielt und erst jetzt
aufgefallen dass sie tatsächlich noch
ein teil darf war den wir ausgelassen
hatten
und zwar fliegen die komplexe vor wir
allerdings auf play drücken muss ich
euch doch etwas ganz kurzes sagen wenn
ich heute den kalender gucke ist jetzt
der 30 november wenn ihr das video
allerdings sieht es der erste dezember
das heißt mit merchandise kommt raus ich
weiß nicht wann das wieder rauskommen
ich denke mal so um 16 uhr um den dreh
und zwar geht der shop um 16 uhr online
das heißt wenn ihr das video seht ist
mein shop online da ich mich überhaupt
nicht mit video editing auskenne und
überhaupt nicht weiß wie man das machen
kann wenn ich euch das einfach mal so
ein ihr könnt auf luca - shop.de zum
glück hat es gar nicht durch gedrückt
auf luca - shop.de könnt ihr nun die
aller kurzen hosen shirts finden
unter anderem tatsächlich auch dass hier
das habe ich halt anders ist sondern mit
ganz vielen smileys und dann könnt ihr
dann noch diesen crew neck hier finden
da ist der smiley drauf gesteckt haben
wir sogar noch ganz normale police wurde
es mir einfach ganz normal darauf
gesprintet ist mit einer kapuze
wir haben hier sogar noch tatsächlich
die sehen so aus mit dem smiley auch
drauf und wir haben sogar noch zwei
weitere shirts im shop und noch einen
jutebeutel der turnbeutel allerdings
liegen die sachen gerade bei mir unten
im auto und es regnet es ist kalt
deswegen die sachen werdet ihr schon
noch im shop sehen doch lugano shop.de
und kaufte meinen
hallo und jetzt fangen wir an mit zocken
okay der ist glaube ich tot wieder diese
typische katar sieger hätte wir sind
hier wohl in einer zelle und müssen raus
wir können uns entweder hoch boosten
einen chart stecke machen für den auf
den transfer warten oder und tod spielen
was würde jetzt machen wir spielen
einfach mal als wenn du tot
zahlen
denn ist
wow
das hätte ich mir tatsächlich anders
vorgestellt diese trockenen sprüche
tricon winzling wer mitgestalten was ich
gerade 15 von der freundin geschickt
bekommen habe lukas schott besser als
calvin klein
die hat es begriffen als zweites würde
ich einfach glaube ich mich auf boston
sogar tatsächlich
neu
als ob das gerade geklappt hat ich würde
mal sagen wir gehen den weg nach links
alle remember that
ich habe dir allein gelassen da unten
ich muss irgendwie den wachen vorbei ich
habe kommend melodie pick pocket
sprinter visitation wir nehmen das
furzkissen
das hat jetzt nicht endlich geklappt
oder ich muss diese wache da oben weg
kriegen ich stehe hier unten und ich
habe die möglichkeiten long shot ring
oder power jump
ich mache den power jump
wir waren noch nie so gut alter gab es
ja schon mal eine fucking statement
folge wo ich direkt zu beginn der alles
bis auf den ersten richtig hatte ich bin
überhaupt kein plan vom bungee springen
deswegen sage ich mal
ein gericht das liegt dann im virgin als
kauft alle menschen als von luca luka
viele schaffen
wenn ich über ein rohr darüber klettern
müsste würde ich freunde ich bin raus
das ist doch kein normales luca video
wenn alles klappt ich muss schon wieder
den wachen vorbei kommen und habe ein
blatt einem boxen einem ich würde ja
eigentlich liebend gerne wieder ein
furzkissen nehmen auch keine karte kommt
freunde ich nehme einfach einen platz
das ist jetzt nicht ernsthaft war
ich habe das nicht wirklich geschafft
wie gut bin ich denn eigentlich entweder
wir nehmen die dinge oder die rakete
oder gottes das lauffest lief die
gewisse
wir haben es geschafft wir haben es
verdammt nochmal geschafft einfach mal
nur aus interesse loks irgendwie auch
anders klappen
ich glaube wirklich auch anders ich
beende hiermit das video ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass ich da so schnell
durchkommen doch das war wahrscheinlich
wieder wirklich sonst dikmen spiel wo
alle sachen irgendwie richtig waren nur
du überall mit einem anderen weg halt
raus kommst wenn ihr noch weitere von
solchen spielen mit anklicken und so
kennt so etwas in die richtung die
statement schreibt für das gerne die
kommentare weil die videos bei euch mal
super ankommt es mir auch sehr viel spaß
macht das ganze zu schneiden und dann
würde ich mich lieber über eine
bewertung freuen wenn euch das video
gefallen hat wenn euch der schnitt
gefallen wenn euch der aufwand gefallen
an dem das video gesteckt habe und dann
könnt ihr jetzt einfach mal auf
lokalnews.de gehen und euch vielleicht
ein t shirt holen oder so oder ein pulli
die sache ist dass die ersten 500
besteller dazu noch einen signierten
sticker bekommen also diesen smiley von
mir das profilbild habe ich
unterschrieben
den könnt ihr dann dazu kriegen das
heißt ihr solltet schnell sein aber ich
will jetzt auch nicht weiter werbung
dafür machen es ist halt einfach mein
merge und ich habe da wirklich wirklich
wirklich 15 jahre daran gearbeitet
es sind halt echt ein paar designs die
ich so noch nicht gesehen habe also das
mit so ganz vielen smileys und das
andere design ist quasi das hat hier
seine tasche und da wenn man die tasche
unternimmt guckt dann erstmal die raus
und so also ein paar echt coole sachen
ich halte mein maul
denn ich bin nicht faul